well india's supreme court has ordered
ordered authorities to shut offices in
the capital new delhi and nearby cities
the order comes after officials ordered
schools to close and construction sites
to stop work to reduce hazardous air
pollution that is blanketing cities in
noxious smog
new delhi is one of the world's most
polluted cities
now it's closed school doors for the
entire week so children can stay inside
away from the smog
not everyone's convinced that's a good
idea
there is a log down because of covet
itself right now they are closing the
screws so i think it's this is not the
solution
because of the toxic air hospitals are
seeing a sharp rise in the number of
patients with breathing difficulties
children among them my daughter
she's quite young she's an infant she's
almost two so
she recently was
checked for
you know some
coffin um fever so it was found that
because of the air pollutants she was
not able to you know be perfectly
healthy
construction work has also been banned
for several days to stop the dust
and government offices like this one
must close until the end of the week
delhi's smog is a noxious mix of
pollutants from its millions of vehicles
and many factories
agricultural fires are also a major
culprit
farmers in regions around the capital
burn the straw or crop stubble left over
from their rice harvest at the onset of
crop winter are falling so we can't
afford to get rid of the straw another
way but to burn it the government should
give us subsidies and machinery or some
ngos should provide us with machinery so
that we have an alternative then farmers
wouldn't need to burn it they won't do
it
delhi's government has vowed to clean
delhi's filthy air but until it manages
to get on top of the problem the
residents of delhi will continue to
suffer
our correspondent nimisha jaiswal is in
delhi for more on this story hi nimisha
this does happen this hazardous air
pollution every year why is that
well sumi the answer to that question
really depends on who you are asking if
you ask the delhi government it says
that the blame is to be laid squarely on
neighboring states that allow for
stubble burning to continue despite the
delhi government offering them a
solution which is a decomposer that can
be used as an alternative to the burning
method it also depends
on on the flip side when you ask the
central government just today at the
supreme court they said that the stubble
burning only contributes about 10
percent to delhi's pollution and that
the delhi government is dropping the
ball when it comes to tackling the local
sources of pollution which include
transport vehicular pollution as well as
industries and dust pollution now while
the blame gets shifted from one party to
the other of course we also see that
there are climatic effects that can
contribute to air pollution the delayed
monsoon this year as well as the winds
that carry in pollution from other
states also contribute to the annual
cycles of pollution and of course delhi
residents suffer in the midst of it
what is the government doing to address
the problem
well there are long term and emergency
responses right now of course schools
have been shut down and
the the construction sites have also
been shut down people are being
encouraged to work from home over the
longer term the delhi government last
month announced that it would be
focusing on monitoring construction
sites to make sure the dust pollution is
curved it also wants to crack down on
waste being burned within the city
itself but it insists that other states
need to step in as well even today the
delhi government said that other states
need to impose lockdowns as well to help
telly out with the pollution situation
but of course once again it looks like
not enough is being done because the
whole city is suffering once again
because of the crisis
yeah tell us more about the impact that
this has on people who live in delhi
well hospitals every year at this point
of time reporters serious spike in
bronchitis complaints and lung in lung
infections and complaints related to
breathing and delhi is also grappling
with the dengue outbreak so healthcare
infrastructure is under pressure and
thankfully coronavirus cases are
remaining low in addition to that
doctors for years now have been telling
parents that the best thing they can do
for their children is to leave the city
and that we are seeing a pattern of that
emerging as well several people are now
migrating as pollution migrants leaving
the city over these months because it be
because for them it is unlivable
dw's nimisha jaxwell reporting for us
from delhi good to talk to you